-You know what I wanted to
bring up to you?
Because it was on the TV
the other day,
and I couldn't turn it off,
because you're amazing in it --
but it was "Lincoln."
-Yeah.
-Steven Spielberg's movie
about Abraham Lincoln.
-That was so much fun.
-You were amazing in that one.
I mean, you're always great,
but this,
you were in the zone, dude.
It was great.
-It was so much fun.
-Did you learn anything?
Or what was Steven like?
Like, was he -- Did you --
-I'd known him beforehand
just socially,
but I had never worked
with him before.
And he was -- he's just
absolutely lovely to work with.
I remember I showed up one day,
and I was walking along
with him,
and it was the beginning of the
day, and we had a big sequence.
There was --
in front of the Capitol,
and it was a -- all these horses
and carriages,
I mean, dozens and dozens
of them,
and on this big, huge set that
had turned it into a dirt road
and, you know, extras all over
the place and military
and all the rest of that.
And I went up, I said, "Steven,
what do you --
what do you think for this?"
And he said -- He looked around
at everything that was going on
and he said, "I don't know.
We'll figure it out."
[ Laughter ]
And that sort of
level of confidence,
what it breeds
is tremendous creativity,
because you are able
to discover things.
-And you're trusting everyone
that's working with you.
-Yeah, and he has great trust
in the people he works with.
He's -- I find him
lovely to work with.
And the film
was just so wonderful.
-And every every single cutaway
to you and every reaction,
I was like,
"That's how you do it."
If you want to watch
good acting, watch James Spader.
James, thank you so much
for being on our show.
"The Blacklist," everybody.
Let's take a look at a clip
from next Friday's episode.
Take a look.
-Your message said you wanted
to talk to Priya.
She's my most valuable asset.
-Which is why I want her
to be an asset of mine.
If she agrees, I'll compensate
you for your loss.
-Pennies on the dollar.
-Pennies on the dollar?!
Dembe, are you listening
to this?
Penny -- I've never paid pennies
on the dollar in my life.
If I'm known for anything,
it's for overpaying.
He's forever trying to get me
to show some restraint.
But listen, we can
resolve this right now.
I can get Edward to take it up
to a few thousand feet,
circle back around,
come in over the 18th hole,
and drop you
right into the grandstand.
We've done it before.
I'm sure we'll do it again.
-Yeah, that's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
James Spader, everybody!
Catch "The Blacklist" Fridays
at 8:00 p.m. on NBC.